I wanted to ask you what does it mean to
you being part of the MCU because uh
you're now a big part of it and are you
surprised you got the call and what has
it been like interacting with friends
and family you know
um I'm delighted to be a part of the MCU
I'm really excited to see to shoot
Thunderbolts which we're going to do
this year it's going to be absolutely
wild
um I uh I'm particularly delighted about
it because it's really the only thing my
kids
are interested in that I've done that's
not true I'm I'm exaggerating but
um
they're interested in this of course but
and and but the point is is that for
years both of my boys have been saying
mom why don't you do a Marvel movie do a
Marvel movie do a Marvel movie and I'm
like gonna be for a Marvel movie and
then they did and I was like oh yeah now
my boys are going to be psyched what
movie did you do I'm sorry fine I was
I'm I I was in uh the wakanda forever
film that just came out and a few and
um Falcon and Winter Soldier thank you
and black widow jeez and but
Thunderbolts is going to be the the big
one coming up